lorsque j'étais enfant j'avais tout
plein d'objectifs tout plein de rêves
dont celui de découvrir le monde à cette
époque là je ne voyageais pas encore
j'ai commencé à arpenter le monde
lorsque je suis entrée en école de
commerce la devise de mon école c'est
apprendre à oser
alors j'étais bien motivés pour mettre
en application cette devise car je suis
convaincu depuis toujours que pour
diverses raisons il faut savoir sortir
de sa zone de confort parfois il faut
savoir avoir de l'audace rompre avec son
quotidien rassurant dans lequel tout est
prévisible et maîtrisé c'est dans cette
école que je vais rencontrer aussi mon
mari est lui aussi avait les mêmes rêves
que moi ils souhaitaient voyager et
n'avait pas encore eu la chance de
voyager durant sa jeunesse à la fin de
mes études je suis devenue avocate au
barreau de paris et c'est en parallèle à
cette activité professionnelle que j'ai
commencé à développer une passion pour
les régions polaires
alors durant mes congés j'ai arpenté le
grand nord le groenland le spitzberg
je suis allé au pôle nord aussi ces
expériences m'ont conduit un jour sur
les côtes du continent antarctique alors
l'antarctique c'est ce continent qui est
tout en bas du globe qui est grand comme
26 fois la france et j'ai vu la base sur
les côtes ce que l'on voit dans les
quelques films les quelques reportages
sur l'antarctique
j'ai vu les icebergs j'ai vu les
manchots
j'ai vu la banquise j'étais subjugué par
la beauté de ce continent mais en même
temps j'étais un peu frustré car j'avais
envie de savoir ce qu'il ya derrière les
côtes du continent antarctique il ya peu
d'image de l'intérieur du continent
en fait il ya peu de personnes qui s'y
aventurent et aucune forme de vie n'a pu
s'adapter à ces conditions extrêmes il
ya un point commun entre tous les
explorateurs polaires qui ont eu la
chance un jour de pouvoir se rendre sur
ce continent ou qui ont eu le courage de
le faire
c'est qu'aucun d'entre eux n'est capable
de déterminer d'où vient cette forte
attirance pour le continent antarctique
une attirance si puissante si tenace que
lorsque l'on rentre chez soi on n'a
qu'une envie c'est y retourner je suis
rentré en france et je pensais souvent à
l'antarctique
alors un jour j'ai eu une idée folle une
idée complètement folle le meilleur
moyen de savoir ce qu'il ya derrière les
côtes du continent antarctique c'est de
le traverser
il ya des idées dont on sait au moment
où les énonce qu elle ne se réaliseront
jamais mais il y en a d'autres qui ne
vous quitte plus c'était il ya déjà
quelques années et je n'imaginais pas
alors qu'un jour je serai là devant vous
pour vous en parler
traverser l'antarctique est ce possible
j'ai commencé à lire et relire des
récits d'explorateurs à me renseigner à
faire des recherches à faire des
rencontres et puis un jour l'idée
devient un objectif
mon objectif c'est traverser
l'antarctique sur 2000 45 km dans points
de la côte du continent à un autre point
de la côte du continent en passant par
le pôle sud sans voile de traction ça
veut dire sans l'aide du vent l'objectif
est extrêmement ambitieux alors certes
je pratique
l'ultra trail je participe à des courses
des compétitions de course à pied sur
longue distance 150 200 km que je
parcours en 24 heures ou 30 heures
d'affilée mais là l'objectif n'a
absolument rien à voir
il est bien plus réels bien plus élevé
les chances de succès sont un film
les risques sont considérables les
obstacles sont nombreux les personnes
qui croyaient en ma capacité de relever
ce défi se comptait initialement sur les
doigts d'une main
j'avoue que la visualisation d'une telle
expédition m'a souvent effrayés angoisse
est terrifié réveillé en pleine nuit
elle m'a souvent donner le vertige
et pourtant j'ai toujours eu l'intimé
conviction au fin fond de moi que
traverser l'antarctique est possible
j'ai préparé je me suis préparé
physiquement j'ai continué à courir des
longues distances
je suis allé un entrepôt frigorifique le
samedi matin à 5h pour courir cinq
heures six heures entre les palettes
j'ai tracté des pneus sur le sable en
bretagne je me suis préparé
logistiquement j'ai trouvé une société
qui accepte de me déposer en avion sur
les côtes du continent antarctique et de
venir me récupérer j'ai cherché à
constituer une équipe
j'ai recherché des partenaires
financiers j'ai convaincu une banque de
m'octroyer un prêt significatif j'ai
trouvé les assurances j'ai obtenu les
autorisations
il m'a fallu trois ans de préparation et
il ya un peu plus d'un an
je suis enfin déposée sur le bord de
l'océan austral en antarctique avec deux
autres aventuriers qui avait le même
rêve que moi découvrir l'intérieur du
continent
mon mari fera aussi partie de cette
aventure
nous sommes le 14 novembre 2014
il est midi exactement alors l'objectif
est simple il faut que je rejoigne le
pôle sud qui se trouve à 3000 m
d'altitude
une fois au pôle sud jeu devrait
redescendre vers la côte pour effectuer
cette traversée en tout j'ai 76 jours le
28 janvier je devrais être à bord du
dernier avion qui quitte la base union
glacier en antarctique pour rejoindre le
chili avec les derniers membres de la
base des quelques scientifiques encore
rester là effectivement je n'ai pas
trouvé les moyens financiers de venir me
faire récupérer en février ou en mars
par un avion qui aura été spécialement
affrétés pour l'expédition
alors je comprends que c'est un défi
face aux éléments à la nature extrême
violence en antarctique mais c'est aussi
un défi de temps je dois parcourir plus
de 2000 kilomètres en traversée en moins
de 80 jours et sans l'aide du vent sans
voile de traction je skie 8h08 créneau
d'une heure entrecoupé de pauses de 10
minutes je tracte un traîneau sur lequel
je porte mes équipements le traîneau est
lourd il pèse plus que mon poids de
corps beaucoup plus en début
d'expédition
il y à des vagues de glace partout il
faut pas imaginer que l'antarctique est
tout plat non en antarctique il y à du
dénivelé
il y à des vagues de glace qui sont
formés par le vent et en début
d'expédition sur les 400 premiers
kilomètres ces vagues occupe tout
l'espace
il est impossible de les contourner
alors je dois les franchir au risque de
casser les skis gelé franchies les unes
après les autres
le traîneau se rend vers toutes les
trois minutes alors je me retourne je
leur adresse et je continue le traîneau
se renverse je me retourne je leur
adresse je continue ainsi de suite
la vitesse est lente en début
d'expédition j'ai emporté avec moi une
fièvre tenace un virus attrapé au chili
il me faudra du temps pour m'acclimater
puis je m'acclimate enfin et là la
température chute drastiquement
il fait plus ou moins 30 degrés il fait
moins 50 degrés et à -50 degrés le corps
comprend qu'il en situation de survie
alors je skie vite j'ai beau être en
hypoglycémie j'ai beau n'avoir aucune
force j'ai beau avoir des douleurs
musculaires je skie très très vite
c'est la seule manière de garder la
chaleur dans mon corps les pauses ne
sont plus de 10 minutes elles sont de 3
minutes
je n'ai pas le temps de refermer ma
poule k j'ai à peine le temps de mâcher
je me casse une dans le vent est un vent
de face jusqu'au pôle sud il est violent
80 km heure
il me repousse violemment la seule chose
que je me demande à ce moment là c'est
quand est-ce que se vend pas m'emporter
au fin fond du continent des extrêmes
j'ai peur j'ai très peur le masque vivre
je n'y vois plus rien impossible de le
relever sur le front risque d'avoir une
gelure à la joue ou non à la cornée
alors je garde le masque sur les yeux et
j'avance sans aucune visibilité et la
température augmente enfin après
plusieurs jours il fait moins 35 qui
fait presque chaud quand on se lance sur
ce type d'expédition il ya aussi une
préparation mentale pendant la
préparation il faut visualiser que
l'imprévisible se produira
nécessairement c'est le meilleur moyen
de mettre l'émotion et le stress à
distance lorsque l'événement se présente
effectivement cela fait plusieurs jours
que je navigue dans le brouillard blanc
il est 15h le brouillard se lève une
heure
j'arrive devant une immense crevasses
plusieurs kilomètres de long plusieurs
mètres de large
cette crevasse je l'avais vu sur les
images satellites
l'itinéraire avait été établi dans le
but de les contourner
mais une erreur de navigation nous
conduit tout droit devant elle alors je
fait marche arrière et je perds plus
d'une journée et ce soir là j'ai deux
options soit je reste optimiste et je
continue soit j'abandonne après tout on
m'a dit tant de fois que traverser
l'antarctique à ski sur plus de 2000
kilomètres sans voile de traction en
moins de 80 jours est impossible
seules trois personnes ont traversé
l'antarctique ans qui s'envole de
traction d'un point de la coupe du
continent à un autre point de la côte du
continent et toutes les trois sur une
distance inférieure à 1750 km les vagues
de glace m'ont ralenti la crevasse
aujourd'hui demain j'aurai d'autres
péripéties c'est impossible mais ce soir
là je reste optimiste
je suis heureuse parce que je suis
vivante si le brouillard ne s'était pas
levé ce jour là je serai actuellement au
fond de cette crevasse alors je continue
33e jours d'expédition alors que la
tante a résisté à tous les vents
catabatiques les plus violents de la
planète elle s'affaisse ce matin-là un
arceau kaas à cause du froid et déchire
une partie de la toile extérieure
là aussi cela ne sert à rien de se
morfondre
alors je continue des péripéties comme
celle là il y en a eu plein pendant
cette expédition
je n'aurai pas le temps de tout vous les
compter mais quoi qu'il en soit le 40ème
jour d'expédition j'atteins enfin le
pôle sud plus tard que prévu certes mais
nous sommes le 23 décembre 2014
je n'aurais pas imaginé de plus beau
cadeau de noël à ce moment là je sais
que quelle que soit l'issue de
l'expédition que je parvienne ou non à
réaliser cette traversée je sais que
l'antarctique ce rapport toujours en moi
et qu'il y aura toujours une partie de
moi-même sur ce continent des extrêmes
je reste 48 heures au pôle sud le temps
de recharge et de nouvelles vivre dans
mon traîneau le temps de faire quelques
photos pour les partenaires
le temps de visiter la base a month and
scott et rencontrer les scientifiques
puis je repars le 25 décembre pour une
véritable course contre la montre j'ai
parcouru 916 km en 40 jours
il me reste désormais 1129 km à
parcourir en 34 jours seulement je veux
croire que c'est possible alors je skie
plus longtemps 10h10 créneau d'une heure
entre coupé de pause de 10 minutes mais
j'ai faim j'ai terriblement fin la fin
et obsessionnelle je ne pense qu'à ça je
n'arrive plus à calculer je n'arrive
plus à réfléchir je n'arrive plus à
analyser je perds beaucoup de poids mais
mu que fondent à ce moment là je peste
39 kg j'aurais dû avoir 4500 calorique
quotidien je n'aurais dû avoir 6000
calories quotidien janet que 4500 dans
mon traîneau
je dois faire avec le 12 janvier 2015 il
me reste 580 km à parcourir et deux
semaines désormais je dois leur faire un
marathon par jour
mais le brouillard blanc m'enveloppe je
l'appelle l'obscurité blanche je ne vois
pas l'horizon je ne vois pas les nuages
je ne vois pas les vagues de glace alors
je tombe je me relève je tombe je me
relève
j'ai les yeux rivés sur la boussole et
parfois je fais demi tour je fait marche
arrière
je suis très lente 24 km 35 km toujours
pas un marathon
alors je skie plus longtemps 11h 12h 15h
je dors quatre heures 5 heures par nuit
je suis comme un zombie au milieu de
l'antarctique fatigué épuisé
j'ai envie de dormir tout en skiant et
puis le brouillard se lève enfin et là
c'est un nouveau décor qui apparaît une
impression de fin du monde
l'horizon est sombre noir
les nuages sont très bas je pense que
c'est la nuit qui commence enveloppé
l'antarctique
nous sommes fin janvier j'ai skié
pendant plus de soixante dix jours sous
le jour permanent il fait jour en
permanence 24 heures sur 24 durant l'été
austral et la nuit commence à
s'installer sur ce continent
le 26 janvier 2015
je me lève ce matin là avec une émotion
toute particulière
il ne me reste plus que 60 km à
parcourir mais 60 km à travers la zone
la plus
passer de l'expédition alors je reste
prudente
je contourne les crevasses interminable
toute la journée je la passe à
contourner les crevasses puis je longe
des montagnes pour la première fois
depuis 70 jours je longe des montagnes
et il y à de véritables pentes de
véritable descente le traîneau passe
devant c'est la première fois
la neige n'est plus blanches la glace
n'est plus blanche elle devient bleue
elle est fragile elle se brise sous
chacun des pas de ski et puis il horizon
il est pas noir il est bleu d'un bleu
profond
nous sommes le 27 janvier 2015
j'ai skié 18 heures ce jour-là il est 3
heures 35 du matin et j'ai atteint la
mer de weddell j'ai traversé
l'antarctique à skis alors c'est la plus
longue expédition réalisé par une femme
en antarctique sans voile de traction
l'objectif était donc très élevé mais
c'est surtout ma plus belle expérience
j'ai vécu soixante quatorze jours une
vie sans confort aucun une vie simple
déterminé par les seules exigences de la
nature
boire manger dormir marché
je ne me suis jamais senti aussi vivante
que durant ce raid qui a duré près de
trois mois alors j'ai voulu partager
j'ai écrit un livre j'ai réalisé un film
mais je sais que je ne parviendrai
jamais à vous faire ressentir
complètement ce que l'on peut ressentir
la base sur ce continent des extrêmes
lorsque l'on fait corps avec lui pendant
plus de soixante dix jours loin de
l'agitation du monde comme toutes ces
expériences qui sont très forts très
riche
elles se vivent plus qu'elle ne se
racontent
mais ce que j'ai voulu c'est transmettre
des messages qui nous tiennent à coeur
il n'y a pas de plus grand risque dans
la vie que de ne jamais en prendre et
les risques que l'on prend aujourd'hui
sont moins lourds à porter que les
regrets que l'on pourra voir demain en
vivant sa vie à moitié la seule limite à
nos objectifs et celle que nous leur
donnons le reste n'est qu'une excuse ou
une peur peut-être merci